o pessoal quando eu vinha para mauá
quando estudava aqui eu ficava quatro
horas por dia dentro de um carro e todos
os meus amigos ficavam duas três horas
por dia dentro de um carro
mais tarde eu vim a saber que a média
dos paulistanos é ficar três horas por
dia dentro de um carro três horas por
dia dentro de um carro vezes cinco dias
vezes quatro semanas vezes 12 meses
são 45 dias úteis por ano que uma pessoa
passa dentro de um carro
eu fiquei pensando será que isso é vida
nas metrópoles será que isso é a vida
que se pode apresentar nas cidades muito
bem fiquei com aquilo na cabeça e
pensando casey vai acontecer com vocês
também
e eu fui morar com minha esposa em um
pequeno apartamento no apartamento cerca
de 30 metros quadrados e esse
apartamento é muito próximo do lugar
aonde a onde eu trabalhava e eu comecei
a fazer alguns trajetos a pé e de
bicicleta alguns dias da semana até que
chegou o ponto que eu abandonei
totalmente o carro
há muitos anos eu já não tenho carro e
amasse uma experiência magnífica 'nossa
carro na cidade magnífica vivacidade de
outra forma e eu vou andando pela cidade
vou conversando com outras pessoas e eu
vejo muitas reclamações
o pessoal fala à nação aguentar essa
cidade é muito stress eu fico horas e
horas no trânsito
como é que pode como é que as pessoas
podem viver nessa cidade eu fico olhando
aquilo que estranho eu não sinto nada
disso
joaquim que trabalha conosco eu
encontrei na recepção todos os dias ou
assim alexandre muito trânsito hoje tá
duro já que não tem a menor idéia do que
está falando eu num vou pra mim não faz
o menor efeito e começamos a pensar
diferente
começamos a imaginar uma nova vida é nas
cidades e como quem tem a ver o trânsito
com um no apartamento
as pessoas hoje querem tempo as pessoas
hoje
buscam uma vida melhor nas cidades e
como a gente consegue apresentar uma
solução para que as possam viver as
pequenas coisas passar mais tempo com a
família por exemplo ou fazer o que elas
gostam o que podemos oferecer para elas
bom aí a gente começa a fazer uma uma
ilusão
antigamente nós estávamos acostumados a
usar os desktops negócio grande mouse e
teclado e quando me apresentaram pela
primeira vez um smartphone
eu ficava pensando como será que a gente
pode digitar escrever e meio e só que é
impossível
hoje eu praticamente não uso o meu
desktop no rio ele por dias e dias e as
possibilidades que me abre dentro de um
smartphone são incríveis
eu levo ele para qualquer lugar eu
trabalho onde eu quero eu tenho
aplicativos incríveis que até então eram
impensáveis e aí porque não por que não
transformar o mercado imobiliário em
alguma coisa com uma plataforma como um
smartphone e desse conceito começou a
nascer um sonho de reinventar a vida das
pessoas na cidade
eu lembro da minha mãe na minha casa
nós temos uma mesa enorme uma mesa de 16
lugares e nós usávamos duas vezes no ano
uma vez na páscoa e uma vez no nosso
novo i
mas se ela faz sentido essa mesma
carregar pagar iptu pagar condomínio uma
manutenção na minha opinião não existe
uma forma de vida muito mas muito mais
eficiente do que a gente conhecia até
então
outro caso muito interessante a dani que
trabalhava e eu vim aqui todos os dias
todas as semanas ela saia correndo pra
poder ir pra casa chega cedo porque uma
vez por semana sem correr pra casa pra
lá chega cedo
ora porque o compra online eu não vou
mais um hipermercado não fica na
marginal duas horas duas horas no caixa
depois duas horas para voltar e eu
compre online só que quando chegam as
compras têm os congelados eles
descongelam então eu tenho que correndo
pra casa porque não oferecer uma solução
que por exemplo ela possa deixar as
coisas dela armazenada
um ambiente refrigerado de forma que ela
possa chegar e receber suas coisas no
momento que ela quiser
sem nenhum estresse então a gente
começou a pensar com essa nova forma de
viver o que as pessoas estão procurando
dentro de uma vida moderna com mais
tecnologia em que as pessoas não querem
gastar o seu tempo e daí a percepção foi
muito simples
hoje nós construímos uma plataforma eu
imagino que cada prédio ou cada a cada
edifício empreendimento que nós
construímos é uma plataforma uma
plataforma na qual na qual nós vamos
lugar os melhores aplicativos as
melhores soluções do mercado para
reinventar a vida das pessoas
então nós temos carro compartilhado
tenham um aplicativo de caronas que
integra as pessoas em um mesmo prédio de
forma que elas possam para o mesmo lugar
juntas em soluções como o
compartilhamento de bicicletas e motos
isso é incrível elas equipe começou a
pensar como solucionar um pequeno espaço
entre as pessoas vivem
nós visitamos site sites é eventos
feiras de aviação feras de barcos e
começamos a estudar os micro espaços
como tomar proveito do espaço de uma
forma melhor tornar tudo mais eficiente
e gerar economia de tempo e economia de
espaço e economia financeira
hoje num apartamento de 19 ou 14 metros
quadrados que é mais ou menos o tamanho
metade do palco
nós conseguimos colocar nove ambientes
diferentes
nove ambientes diferentes
então imaginem ele vira um theater
ele vira um home office você pode dormir
na cama de casal
casal é possível colocar a cozinha área
de serviço em 14 metros quadrados
mas com tanto que nós promovemos uma
solução que é uma plataforma que tenha
outros valores agregados que inventem a
vida das pessoas
enfim a minha filhinha é tá com 89 anos
e vocês que têm filhos nesta idade sabem
como é terrível a hora de dividir os
brinquedinhos as coisas principalmente
com o irmão ea aldeia dividir ela vira
bicho a louca quando alguém tenta
mexer nas coisas dela e outro dia a
professora falou para levar um livro pra
escola
e daí ela a professora pediu para que
cada aluno colocar seus livros no chão e
eles trocaram entre os amiguinhos
ela chegou em casa em casa falou olha
papai todo o livro da sofia
eu peguei emprestado e ela começou a
perceber que quando você compartilha é
muito bacana
além de você ganhar uma nova história a
mamãe o papai não gastaram absolutamente
nada para aquela historinha a gente
matou - árvore
preservamos o planeta maravilhoso no
nosso dia-a-dia hoje sequer percebemos a
nós vemos por exemplo bicicletas
compartilhadas nos vemos no carro
compartilhado por um aplicativo
apartamentos compartilhados já passou a
fazer parte do nosso cotidiano uma
biblioteca por exemplo e trouxemos o
compartilhamento para cada prédio quando
você aplica conceitos de
compartilhamento as pessoas vivem muito
mais felizes elas podem interagir com as
pessoas podem fazer uma viagem juntas
podem ir para uma lavanderia se conhecer
e tem uma série de itens são possíveis
aplicar dentro do empreendimento como
por exemplo o carro compartilhado o
fábio acabou de comprar um apartamento
ele deu o carro dele como parte de
pagamento ele não usa mais o carro
ele mora num apartamento que ele vai a
pé para o trabalho e quando ele precisa
usar o carro ele usou o carro
compartilhado
olha que bacana um carro compartilhado
entre todos os moradores de um edifício
e ele usa conforme demanda não só pagar
ipva não só pagar seguro só pagar a
manutenção é maravilhoso estou nem a
vida dele muito mais eficiente ele está
milhões de vezes mais felizes
o principal e adriane comprar um
apartamento eles moravam em alphaville
ficavam duas horas pra vir da castello
duas horas para voltar e resolveram sair
de uma casa enorme em alphaville e morar
num apartamento de 40 metros quadrados
neles ele chega para mim a minha vida em
40 metros quadrados que o meu o meu é
meu escritório está o espaço de um
elevador porque o prédio comercial fica
junto com o residencial eu estou
encontrando a minha esposa eu não falava
com a esposa
a gente sai para jantar isso é
maravilhoso a gente mudou a vida de uma
pessoa e cada vez que o encontro
clientes pessoas que aderiram a um novo
estilo de vida isso é o meu combustível
isso faz a nossa nossa empresa essa
filosofia de querer mudar a vida das
pessoas que tanto nos move e é tão
satisfatória e me perguntam hoje quer
dizer você bolou um tipo de vida em que
você tem um apartamento pequeno próximo
trabalho próximo ao metrô próximo à
escola em que a pessoa pode publicar uma
série de aplicativos lá dentro
alguns deles compartilhados ea vida das
pessoas fica melhor
e qual é o tamanho ideal do apartamento
é o nano apartamento é o giga
apartamento
tanto faz eu não trabalho no mercado
imobiliário
eu não trabalho com apartamentos eu
trabalho e melhorar a vida das pessoas
na cidade
isso é tudo é isso que nós queremos
fazer mudar a vida das pessoas na cidade
existe uma cidade muito melhor do que a
gente conhece hoje e há um tempo atrás o
meu grande e guru chegou para mim e
falou assim olha alexandre nós do
mercado imobiliário
nós trabalhamos muito nós trabalhamos de
segunda a segunda tudo acontece
principalmente nos finais de semana eu
vou te dar um conselho
ouvi ele era a pessoa que eu mais
admirava até então no mercado
olha eu levo todos os dias os meus
filhos à escola leva todos os dias meu
filho à escola eu recomendo que você
faça o mesmo
não entendi muito bem minha esposa
estava grávida da nossa primeira filha
nasceu cresceu e e eu adotei
pra minha vida sagrado
todos os dias eu levo os meus filhos à
escola a pé
é um momento mágico pessoal momento
mágico aos dois ea gente vai conversando
vai rindo brincando
é um momento maravilhoso e eu coloquei
como um sonho que se eu ver mais paz
levando os seus filhos todos os dias à
escola eu vou ter cumprido a minha
missão
obrigado